the capitol hill police exist for a
single reason to protect the capital
which is the home of our legislature
which is the heart of our democracy our
elected members of congress but since
january 6 the capitol hill police force
has been subverted by nancy pelosi who
oversees it and joe biden the new
president to become a kind of secret
police force that acts on behalf of the
democratic party think we're overstating
that we're not
members of the capitol hill police have
been surveilling elected members of
congress their staff and visitors to
their offices
republican congressman troy nails of
texas said that capitol hill police
officers entered his congressional
office last year without his knowledge
and then photographed confidential
materials within the office now if you
haven't worked on capitol hill or around
it it's hard to overstate how completely
out of bounds that is in any other
administration under any other speaker
that would be considered a complete
outrage now it's just par for the course
plainclothes capital police officers
from the department's quote intelligence
division subsequently questioned one of
the congressman's aides about what was
on a whiteboard within his office
on twitter the congressman wrote quote
so why is the capital police leadership
maliciously investigating me in an
attempt to destroy me and my character
congressman troy nels joins us now
congressman thanks so much for coming on
it's hard to overstate how shocking this
story is these are the people who are
paid to protect you
and they're spying on you
an elected member of congress speaking
of an attack on our democracy
tell us
why you think this happened why were
they in your office
well i think well first of all thank you
for having me and i think it's very
clear
you know uh leader mccarthy selected me
to be one of the five to be on the
select committee looking into january
6th and i've been a very vocal critic of
january 6 specifically the capital
police the the leadership of the capitol
police the intelligence section and been
very vocal about it i mean all the
intelligence was there it was glaring to
them it was in their face that that we
knew the capital was the target for
january 6th we knew that
that there were maps that were scattered
throughout the whole city about the
tunnels on january 6. so all the
intelligence was there they knew the
extremist groups are going to be there
and they did nothing with it so i've
exposed this and i've been very vocal
about it i've been vocal too even on
your program a few months back about the
death of ashley babbitt and questioning
why lieutenant byrd's investigation did
not go to a grand jury so this really
doesn't surprise me quite honestly i'm
being targeted right now and and i
believe that that nancy pelosi is
weaponizing the u.s capitol police to
investigate me to try to silence me
intimidate me and quite honestly to
destroy me
this is totally third world and crazy
and it's hard to believe it's happening
in the capital city by the way i should
note their claim is they were trying to
protect you but of course they never
told you about it if there was a threat
they should of course alert you you're
the member of congress why don't you
shut these people down how can you have
nancy pelosi's secret police force in
your office and no one shuts them down
well the claim is that they discovered
one of my office doors wide open on a
saturday afternoon the officer entered
my office and said you know to check to
see if anybody was there that shouldn't
be there and saw suspicious writings on
my white board whereas where i draft my
legislative proposals couple days later
i've got these secret agents secret
agents from the capitol police knocking
on my office door questioning my staff
one of my staffers as to the language on
that board why was there body armor
written on your board interrogating this
this staffer asking him
questions related to a handwritten map
of the rayburn office building which is
an office building for congr for members
of congress and the x on it i mean
absolutely silly absolutely ludicrous
why were the capitol police inside my
office investigating me and i was under
a criminal investigation the chief of
police manger is he's downplaying this
but i'm telling you they're coming after
anyone that has a dissenting point of
view anybody that doesn't agree with
them it happened to me sir i believe the
nsa had happened to you looking at your
emails text messages
obama used the fbi to go after donald
trump russia collusion and we know how
that turned out so they're weaponizing
these federal law enforcement agencies
and an intelligence agencies
we can it's making my heart beat faster
we can't put up this is the red line
that you can't tolerate in a free
society you cannot use federal law
enforcement agencies to go after your
political enemies period so they do in
africa we cannot allow that here
obviously i hope you i hope you get
every one of these cretans fired i mean
it too well the congressman
the office of inspector general was in
my office last week he has agreed to do
a study and an investigation an
independent investigation and i feel
good about that we're going to get to
the bottom of it i hope you will i hope
you will thank you for joining us
tonight thank you god bless
god bless hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else